we have the ability to actually change
the story all the time
if you can move the horizon to something
you know you can complete
and you reward that you essentially are
where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious states of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
want wanna be happy build a life not
just a business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the
10 neuroscience hacks that can make you
unstoppable enjoy
okay let's kick it off with hack number
one control the narrative with dr moran
surf memories are about different in how
they work
and what if i summarize it in one
sentence they change
every time you use them so if you have a
memo installed here of what you had for
lunch yesterday and i asked you what did
you have for lunch you basically open
the memory right now and you tell me a
story
but whatever happens right now goes into
the store and you save it differently
and if i ask you tomorrow what you had
for lunch you'll open the modified
version
so every time i ask you the same
question you open a different version
which means you can actually change the
past you can actually change
your experience of things this is why
therapy works right you go your
girlfriend breaks up with you you go to
the therapist she asks you
what happened you tell the story she
intervenes you save it differently you
ask you a week after what happened you
tell a different story
after five meetings you have a different
version of the reality and that is
powerful because it means that we
control the narrative that we have
we don't really have to be kind of
confound to the
story that we experienced we can
actually change it this is what a brain
is for
to simulate and change and adjust and
synthesize
better version of life we can make
ourselves happy
we can make bad things look better we
can control things and it's all
by virtue of just telling a story
looking it differently and saving it
again it's as simple as that we have the
ability
to actually change the story all the
time so learning is one way to do that
thinking and reflecting about ourselves
another way to do that having more
experiences
allows us to do that hack number two
avoid disrupted sleep with dr rahul john
dial
even if you can get a few hours of sleep
don't do it
really yeah disrupted sleep as residents
and people can write in we if you can
just get an hour
to sometimes it's better to stay up the
whole night and it's a story
well worn between residents they pass
that on to each other
and the reason is the sleep disruption
can be quite difficult on the brain
and so if you're going to get five good
hours of sleep going on to people who
aren't in surgical training
maybe that's better than seven hours of
disrupted sleep where your phone is
going off
and different things are pinging your
way so that's one lesson i think people
should understand
in my family what we do is i actually
start
you know i start turning the lights down
in the house i'm gonna make it dark but
i just take off the the flood lights and
i start getting more ambient light
it's just like a a trigger for your mind
in my opinion and for my boys uh to like
there's a transition coming here
you have to ref down in your thought but
the light change
is the trigger and it's not melatonin in
the back your brain that everybody's
been talking about
it's actually called a suprachiasmatic
nucleus you can get to it through your
nose
and there uh there's a small cluster
that is a circadian rhythm
setter we all of us plants and animals
have been on this revolving earth and
are in tune to it
that it's a it's the daily revolution of
the earth's rhythm that we're in tune
with it's not
the pineal gland releasing one magic
chemical that makes you fall asleep
when we cut out the pineal gland when
they have tumors or cysts
they sleep just the same afterwards i've
done the surgery myself
we don't worry that if we take out the
pineal gland they're not going to sleep
the next day
that this that's the only thing that
makes melatonin but we know when we go
through the nose and we mess with this
area by the hypothalamus
their temperature regulation is off
they're like 104 for no reason
their sleep is off so sleep is a very
complicated thing that cannot be
addressed just with melatonin
i believe you can catch up on sleep
during the weekends
and the way to get into sleep rhythm is
to not have a stimulant
and start shaving the light as you get
later on at night that's the way i would
approach
you know all the issues with sleep that
are going on hack number three
try exposure therapy with dr moriel
zelikowski
if you're afraid of flying you can go to
a clinic
and you know get in a fake airplane and
kind of do that repeatedly over and over
and in a form of exposure therapy or
cognitive behavioral exposure therapy
where you kind of re relive the
traumatic event or
experience the cues that predict trauma
without the trauma itself so that's
fairly typical how does that help so i
mean
it's actually a lot of that's also based
on rodent research and so what you do
when you
do exposure therapy is you build a new
memory so a memory that
actually i can get in this airplane and
everything's gonna be fine i can
drink my wine and eat the crackers or
whatever
i can get on this plane and actually the
world's not gonna end it's gonna be okay
so that's
you're really forming a second new
memory there and a lot of people have
worked on that it's called you know
extinction learning or what we think of
as exposure therapy
and during that new learning you can
again learn that the plane doesn't mean
something terrible is gonna happen and
then those two memories compete
one that getting on an airplane you know
leads to something terrible and the
other that getting an airplane
usually leads to everything being fine
and great and so
um by doing exposure therapy you're
really kind of strengthening that
extinction memory and you know kind of
making that memory the primary one that
you retrieve when you get on an airplane
hack number four reward the effort with
andrew huberman
when you start thinking about things
like growth mindset in terms of how they
convert to neurochemical signatures
it leads us to this place of okay if
it's all subjective then
you know if i just say look i'm going to
stand up out of my chair and and that's
going to feel amazing is that going to
work well no
it depends on the meaning that i attach
to something and this and this
subjective part can be a little tricky
and a little bit hard for people
so i want to try and lay it out in a in
a concrete way so that if they want to
apply
this they can um incidentally or not so
incidentally i should say
when you look at communities of very
high performers and i'm fortunate enough
to do some consulting with some
people from special forces communities
and so forth they're very good
as are you at attaching a reward
to specific behaviors in subjective ways
so growth mindset
and these dopamine rewards that we
subjectively apply are not
about saying oh you know i had a
terrible day
i performed poorly but you know what
it's great i just feel great anyway
it's not about that it's not about
attaching your sense of reward
to the ultimate goal it's about
attaching your sense of reward to the
fact that you're making action steps
that are generally in the right
direction
the more you can reward the effort
process
the better off you are at building these
kinds of neural circuits and these kind
of tendencies
to be able to lean into anything
challenging over essentially any
duration
so how does this work like how would
somebody do this right
well keeping in mind that adrenaline and
epinephrine
are all great for getting us into action
this is mother nature's way of
chemically making us feel kind of
agitated remember
stress was designed to agitate us to
move us away from things and toward
things
but realizing that that's a limited
resource that eventually
that same chemical is what makes you
have a negative mindset it feels painful
it's the burn in your body it's
uncomfortable
and realizing that dopamine can push
back on that neurochemically
it can suppress those sensations of
wanting to quit you say well then how do
i get this dopamine to work for me
before i hit a goal because not every
day is going to be a real win there's
some days
i mean i know from my science career
there were days that were really hard
experiments didn't work
papers got rejected and yet you know
i've spent two decades or more just
drilling on and drilling on and it's
been a sheer pleasure at times
but there's been you know some pain
points along the way so
what is this process really about and
how would somebody implement these
dopamine and epinephrine type
nor chemical events in their own life
well we all know the example of like
wanting to run a marathon i've never run
a marathon but
that'd be a nice goal to have let's say
tomorrow morning i set my shoes near the
door
now a lot of people have talked about
this day one you set your shoes near the
door day two you go out the door day
three you run around the block day four
but the key thing is not just to go
through the actions but when you hit
each one of those self-designated
milestones the milestones that you're
setting out for yourself you have to
pause for a moment
and tell yourself i'm heading in the
right direction i haven't run the
marathon yet
but this is the foundation upon which
i'm going to lay another foundation upon
which i'm going to lay another
foundation
and those little pulses of dopamine
allow you
to get that action step without the
depletion that it would normally bring
otherwise you're just like you're
spending money this is like replenishing
this bank account that you have and it's
a neural bank account
and so dopamine is the is the thing that
you can control the dosing of and so if
you say
today it's my shoes at the door but
tomorrow it's around the block
and that's it but that's in the
direction i want to go
what you do is you now get those two
events plus the next day the mile long
runners and so forth
without it depleting you it actually
builds this capacity
to build more reward and this is what
you've done this is what people from
elite special forces can do they know
how to make small
simple physical steps in the real world
that allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing
they they know they keep the end in mind
but they get very micro
they move the horizon in very close and
so
if you can move the horizon to something
you know you can complete
and you reward that you essentially are
where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything
and it feels a little weird because none
of us like to reward things that
aren't external but the ability to
control these internal reward schedules
is everything also if you want to have
more confidence self love self belief
check out my 254 series
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
so i've designed a special free
program to help you get it where i will
send you an unlisted video
to your email for the next 254 days to
shift
your self-belief forward the link to
sign up for free
is in the description below you were up
and dressed and ready to go before your
parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected hack number
five get more inputs with david
eagleman what are the things to do to to
keep an
active brain and so on it's getting more
inputs it's
it's because every new thing every new
idea every new situation that you see
goes into that pot and can be stirred up
and you say oh that new thing i saw
that's kind of like this thing if i put
that together with that thing
here's this new idea here's this new
thing didn't you say once that the brain
is built on association yeah that's
right so
yeah how's that useful the um
um so just to explain it the the idea is
that
instead of things being stored like in a
computer instead
i associate everything with other things
that i've
input or learned before so for example
when i smell
coffee that remin that triggers the
association of what coffee will feel
like on my hands
and the name of the barista at starbucks
and the sound of a grinder
and what it'll make me feel like all
these things are in this big network of
association
that's how that's the secret of how the
brain is storing everything i think it's
that everything
sits in this giant network and and
that's what allows us to manipulate
ideas and think about okay well wait i
know this is associated with it and
that's associated with that
so how do i put these all together to
build something
hack number six get rid of the weeds
with dr joe dispenza just because you
have a thought
doesn't necessarily mean it's true so if
you think 60 to 70 000
thoughts in one day and we do and 90 of
those thoughts are the same thoughts as
the day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
your life's not going to change very
much because the same thought leads to
the same choice the same choice leads to
the same behavior
the same behavior creates the same
experience and the same experience
produces the same emotion
and so then the act of becoming
conscious
of this process to to begin to become
more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition
and so then why is that important
because the more
conscious you become of those
unconscious states of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought is not going to slip by your
awareness
unchecked because you're it means to
know thyself and the word meditation
means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self
you're retiring that old self as you
fire and wire new thoughts and condition
the body into a new emotional state
if you do that enough times it'll begin
to become familiar to you so
it's so important just like a garden
if you're planting a garden you got to
get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out
the rocks that sift to the top that are
like our emotional blocks they have to
be removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to
we have to make room to plant a new
garden so primarily
we learn the most about ourselves and
others when we're uncomfortable
because the moment you move into that
uncomfortable state normally a program
jumps in when that program jumps in it's
because the person doesn't want to be in
the present moment and engage it
consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life they're less likely to emotionally
react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to
prune synaptic connections and sprout
new connections we have to
unfire and unwire and re-fire and rewire
we have to unmemorize emotions that are
stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram
that's the act and it's a two-step
process hack number seven
boost your brain health with dr uma nedu
starting with a turmeric with black
pepper
it's a spice that not only hits the high
notes in several conditions there's a
definite association with cognition
so if it's something you cook with or
not a quarter t
at least a quarter teaspoon a day with a
pinch of black pepper
paprine activates the curcumin makes it
more viable by very huge percent
to both the body and the brain tip right
there
and for those people who don't cook with
it add it to a soup or smoothie or a tea
these are good options for you it turns
out that the polyphenols and olive oil
became um uh more available
when they were used in a sofrito
preparation so different cultures have
different
uh types of surfaces what's that sofrito
so frito
is the base for it could be the base for
a gumbo it could be the base but it's
basically onions
garlic some cultures have chili pepper
it's different varieties of that but a
particular study showed that
this reaction made the polyphenols more
available
so i say you know if you're going to
cook use the use the good olive oil use
that gentle
simmering temperature you know use those
ingredients because onions garlic they
they are great prebiotic foods
good for your gut feed the good bacteria
why not throw them in
and then you know there are also other
spices
things like cinnamon saffron rosemary
ginger and sage
that had some good results in a good
data in association with just protecting
cognition coffee the the suggestion was
have coffee but have you know
less than 400 milligrams a day because
depending on the size of your cup that
could be about two to three cups
have them early in the day alcohol was
not
an entirely negative one but at the same
time it's all about
things in moderation and if i if someone
is drinking alcohol i generally suggest
red wine because of the rose
resveratrol but you know you also asked
me about brain fog
and this is where the antioxidant luteal
and
rich foods came in and and there were
studies that showed that
if you incorporate juniper berries fresh
peppermint sage
thyme certain types of hot and sweet
peppers
these apparently are all luteal and rich
foods
celery seeds parsley artichokes and
dried mexican
oregano they actually helped with the
brain fog so
you know i say to people if you're
struggling with that you want to kind of
sharpen
things up start to in spices you'll find
throughout the book
and one of the reasons they're one of my
favorite things is that they
last a long time they salt free
sugar-free calorie-free because i'm not
suggesting a mix that has
added sodium in it but they they hit the
handles on
lots of different conditions and so it's
worth
stocking up on those and it turns out
that for brain fog they can
certain spices can be pretty useful hack
number eight
meditate and be mindful with dr david
polmatter
this is something we spend a third of
our lives doing or we should we don't
spend a third of our lives exercising or
eating which are important obviously
but so underrated in our world of trying
to be productive and getting a leg up on
the next person
you want to be productive sleep more and
sleep
better in terms of the quality um
i you know we look at a lot of things
certainly we talk about meditation
research demonstrates dr andrew
newberg's led us
in in this area indicates that
meditation lights up the prefrontal
cortex
you can do functional mris on people who
do meditation
and they can be only a short period of
time six weeks
they have now lit up their prefrontal
cortex in terms of brain activity can
you imagine
what a tonic blessings themselves like
to do impulse control like i need to sit
here i need to focus on my breath
what is it that's lighting it up what
the act of mindfulness
is lighting up their prefrontal cortex
and it can be mindfulness towards a
prayer it can be mindfulness towards a
mantra
it can be a simple breath whatever
is mindful allows the prefrontal cortex
to light up
and i would submit that that is a big
goal of ours today and that is to be
mindful of whatever activity
uh we are engaged in uh you know there's
people say oh i i'm really good at
multitasking well
nobody can actually multitask we go from
one task
to another task and then back to the
first task or the third task
we're always skipping around we're not
really engaging many tasks
and our efficiency when we are so-called
multitasking or engaging
many issues at one time is a lot less
than if we stayed on one task
being mindful allows better decision
making
being on your smartphone during
a meal leads to an increased consumption
average of 200 calories
because you are not mindful of what you
are doing i remember years ago i
attended a lecture by deepak chopra
and he said somebody asked the question
dr shopra
what can i do about my cigarette smoking
and he said to this person
the next time you want to smoke a
cigarette and you should
stop what you're doing go outside
sit down and think about cigarette
smoking while you're smoking
and what he was saying is being mindful
of that act you know we all know that's
a health destructive
act but i would submit that the reason
he said that is because that individual
is now
not going to mindlessly smoke on the
phone or during a meal or doing the
while driving and that will be an
improvement for that individual
likely he or she will smoke less and
finally make that connection
to the negativity of what that cigarette
smoking is doing to his or her body
so first of all it focuses us to
dedicating a certain time to that
activity in the day
so it's helping us triage our day and of
course the amplification of the
prefrontal cortex
activity meditation reduces
inflammation that's our goal meditation
reduces cortisol
why do we want to reduce cortisol the
stress hormone because cortisol among
other attributes
disrupts our gut bacteria and leads to
increased gut leakiness and permeability
another mechanism that leads to
inflammation
hack number nine cleanse your brain with
matthew walker
we never thought that the brain had its
own cleansing mechanism
and we all know that the body has that
mechanism it's called the lymphatic
system
but it was only um probably six or seven
years ago that a remarkable scientist
macon nedergaard at the university of
rochester made
a stunning set of discoveries in mice
what she found was that the brain
actually does have its own cleansing
system
it's called the glymphatic system named
after the glial cells in the brain that
make it up
now if that wasn't remarkable enough she
went on to find two additional
discoveries
the first is that that
sewage system is not always switched on
in high flow volume
across the 24-hour period it's
specifically during deep sleep
when that that cleansing mechanism kicks
into high gear
and as you said these brain cells will
actually shrink
and allowing the cerebrospinal fluid to
wash away
all of the metabolic detritus that's
been building up whilst we're awake
because make no mistake about it from a
biochemical perspective
wakefulness is low level brain damage
and sleep is sanitary salvation
and the third thing that she discovered
which is something you mentioned there
one of the pieces of toxic metabolic
protein
product that that cleansing system was
washing away
was something called beta amyloid which
is what we know is a protein culprit in
the cascade of alzheimer's disease
and we've now done a lot of work and
others have done this work showing that
insufficient sleep may be one of the
most significant lifestyle factors
determining whether or not you will
develop alzheimer's disease in later
life
and it seems to be that it's this
particular state
of deep sleep and these pulsing these
slow
pulsing electrical big powerful brain
waves that happen during deep sleep
that may be driving the pulsing of this
cerebrospinal fluid and this is
wonderful work by laura lewis at boston
university most recently in humans
that are coupled to the brain waves that
you have so the reason that it's this
specific state which was your question
why deep sleep in particular
because it's only that time period where
we get these huge
powerful deep brain waves and we get the
shrinking
of the cells and we get therefore the
flow
of this pulsing glymphatic system so in
other words it's
it's almost like a power cleanse for
your brain you know it's good night
sleep clean
as it were in that regard and hack
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips
is move to the beat with andrei
viscontas
then there's this view that instead of
thinking about
music as the kind of byproduct or or or
of evolution directly what if we
consider music as a tool
that allowed us to then you know survive
and reproduce in a better way a little
bit like fire
so one of the reasons why we are able to
house these pretty
um relatively large uh very
metabolically costly brains in our
skulls
um is because we are able to cook our
food and get a lot of calories
from not a lot of effort so if you think
about a gorilla
a gorilla is on average physically
larger than a human but its brain is on
average
smaller and the reason is is that the
gorilla has a raw diet and it needs to
spend most of its time
chewing and eating to fuel that you know
rel that
you know big brain right so we actually
have a brain that
is about the size that we should given
uh primates of our size but we've
somehow managed to fuel it which other
primates have not been able to do
by you know cooking so in a sense you
could argue that music can have a
similar
uh trajectory in terms of its importance
so
if cooking allowed us to get a lot of
food into and then you know fuel our
brains
maybe music is something that we did
with all of that free time
that allowed us to exchange ideas and
emotions and
connect with each other uh in ways that
we wouldn't have and i don't just mean
singing or creating noise but also
beat right so beats are a part of music
a big part of it they're tied to our
ability to move
and so one of the things that we see is
that you know both kids
and probably our evolutionary ancestors
learn to move better
in a more coordinated fashion by
synchronizing to a beat
and that beat synchrony is is an
important feature of how we develop
relationships within groups so for
example if you
um are bouncing in sync with someone
else
in the room uh then chances are you
actually feel more empathy you feel
kinder
more generous towards that person
there's there's uh you know a study for
example where an experimenter at the end
of the experiment dropped a bunch of
pencils and
you know if during the experiment uh she
had she had bounced in sync
with the other people who were
participating they were more likely to
pick up her pencils
um compared to a a condition in which
she was out of sync with them so
and so i think that that that my my sort
of so far my favorite
kind of theory of of the evolution of
music comes from this idea of it as a
tool
that helps us sort of form civilization
in a number of different ways
it helps us exchange ideas it helps us
feel connected to others
it helps us express our emotions it
helps us
do things that are ritualistic that are
that connect us like you know grieving
and
marriage and i know other kinds of
ceremonies and that's
how music has sort of helped shape
society
in addition to helping us understand
language too because of course
you know when you're when you're talking
to a baby and the baby is in their
infant you know language development
phase
the baby's really paying attention to
the rhythm of what you're saying
not to the content so much that comes
later
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and you
get motivated the sign
says you have a 35 chance of actually
following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 percent change
of you actually
following through on the plan you set
for yourself so i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week
leave it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate you
it is healthy and necessary to feel all
of the human
emotions when you ask people what do you
want in life most people say
i want to be happy wait hold on now
if grandma dies do you want to be happy
that's it like really
when your child is sick do you want to
be happy no no i think the answer is
that we want to
feel all of the human experience to its
fullest
but never lose our self in it but to
experience
all of it and so we're getting into the
weeds in some very esoteric
and non-scientific thinking right now
but the practice is that if i care about
you deeply the mistake i can make in
your life
is to help you feel like it's all okay
like oh it's okay
it's okay that you're drinking and
driving and you killed a 14 year old
that's
no problem like you'll do better next
time
no the the work is to say what's this
like for you
to feel that pain so you make the
commitment to say no no
i can't do this anymore and that's when
it becomes really real
in the last 50 years in particular we
have experienced what
comparative religious scholar machia
eliader used to call techniques of
ecstasy
and in that category which remain more
or less constant
for thousands of years in the last 50
years we've experienced a
step function in increase of potency and
efficacy
in three major areas technology
psychology and pharmacology
so think back to the early 60s for a
minute think back to bob dylan
playing an acoustic guitar in the
greenwich coffee shops
right now imagine him plugging in at the
newport folk festival
able not just to reach dozens and
hundreds but thousands
and now hendricks channeling the vietnam
war through an upside down
fender strat at woodstock to 80 000
and now a quarter of a million candy
flipping high schoolers
at electric daisy carnival getting their
brain waves entrained at 140 beats a
minute
[Music]
potent unprecedented
in the realm of psychology think back to
the organization man and betty homemaker
coming out of world war ii
fast forward to the 60s fritz pearl at
esslin pillow thumping gestalt sessions
70s radical encounter est groups
eighties and nineties tony robbins giant
within make
bank and date hot chicks all the way to
today
with oprah and eckhart non-dual
awareness beamed out to suburban
housewives by the millions we have more
room to roam
more room to consider who we are who we
might become
and lastly the most obvious pharmacology
from the 50s in the realm of mother's
little helper
barbiturates and valium to today
we've entered a world of full-on
psychopharmacology choose the person
you'd like to be
and pop that pill oxytocin
prozac nation
and despite all of those benefits
despite all that advance
right we're no further than we've always
been
it's easier than ever
to get high and it's as hard as it's
always been
to stay that way so what's up with that
what's up why do we keep pulling an
icarus and falling back to earth
well a helpful analogy is to think of
our self-systems
like a colander and when there's enough
flow
going into that leaky bucket temporarily
it fills up for a moment we experience
the wholeness
we experience the wisdom we experience
the insights and we say ah
yes i remember what i forgot
but when the pill wears off when the
workshop ends
when the djs turn on the floodlights
after the final encore
and the spigot of that peak experience
ceases the perforations in our vessel
take precedent and by monday morning
we're back more or less to where we were
now what do most of us do most of the
time we say ah yeah
let me go get some more of that
we go try to ring the bell again and
again
we become bliss junkies we become hooked
on the state
without ever raising the stage
but what if just for a moment we could
entertain the project
of turning our calendars into chalices
what if we can use those peak
experiences to make us whole
to render us holy what might we do with
just one drop
what could we do with the rest
and in houston smith's immortal words
might we begin then
to transform our passing illuminations
into abiding light the normal
range of psychological suffering you
know not clinical depression but just
feeling like you know life sucks and
you're a failure and there's nothing you
know it's like
you're just it's you're stuck
that is a story of telling yourself a
story you're thinking
and you can either become more and more
mindful of that
and interrupt that more and more
and or and it should be and you can
reframe this continually and tell
yourself a better story
right you can actually just engineer
you know you can you can change the code
that you're that you're
you know running moment-to-moment
and i mean just you know a very simple
one which i you know i use and i
actually
recently recorded this in a lesson on
the app you know just
gratitude just thinking this is actually
you know this particular maneuver is
i believe comes from stoic philosophy i
i didn't actually get it from stoic
philosophy but this
this sort of use of negative imagination
where you
think of all of the bad things that
haven't happened to you
right so if you're just you know if
you're stuck in traffic driving to the
job that you don't like
and you're you're frustrated
uh you can think of all the things that
could happen to you right that haven't
and if any
one of them happened to you you would
consider your prayers answered if you
could just be returned to this moment
right like you haven't been diagnosed
with cancer right you've got two
young kids say you know you want to live
to see them grow up
and you could be the guy who today is
going to find out you've got
two months to live right and you have to
then the next two months is spent
just unwinding your worldly affairs
right
you're not that guy right that hasn't
happened to you yet
that's just more thinking but it can
have a profound effect you can
you can reframe your experience in a way
that doesn't actually change anything
material about your circumstance
and it can let the light in i know in my
particular case
i didn't believe i wasn't smart enough
because when i moved
at five years old from israel to
montreal i spoke hebrew
i didn't read hebrew or write it but i
spoke it i was just learning the
alphabet
i was put into a classroom with 50 kids
all speaking french and english was the
second language they were all speaking
so i sat there for two years looking at
the fall
and not only did i feel stupid
you know i remember i'm 55 now so this
is 50
years ago i remember kids spitting on me
in the playground because i couldn't
speak english
so i'd get into fights all the time i'd
end up in the principal's office my
parents would be called into school
your son's not doing well in school he's
having fights with the other kids
and i was frustrated and the teachers
didn't have time to work with me
on teaching me a language god i didn't
know the alphabet
so i was two years behind for
my entire schooling up until grade 11
when i quit
i said enough is enough so i had
developed this
belief that i wasn't smart enough
where'd that come from now i know i'm
freaking brilliant
and i'm not saying that in an
egotistical way but i study quantum
physics studying neuroscience i know
sometimes i love it and i can
understand it but the point i want to
make is i developed this
pattern in my brain that i wasn't good
enough just because of my experience as
a
five-year-old and i carried that on
for about 15 years until i was 19
and i had a mentor you know asked me why
do i think i left school why do i think
i was getting in trouble why was i
working for two dollars and 30 cents an
hour when i
clearly could speak and talk and
communicate um
i said well they told me i wasn't going
to amount to much it's only if i didn't
get a college degree
i wasn't going to be smart enough to get
a job at a company and i wouldn't have
any retirement i wouldn't have any
ability to contribute
i couldn't make enough money to take
care of myself my family's i believed
what
what the people that i'm supposed to
believe told me
so i developed this neuron cluster
around my
own self-belief that i was not smart
enough and as a result of that
i couldn't do well in the real world so
what did i do
from 12 to 17 i lied stole cheated
sold drugs did break in and entries did
counterfeit
money uh whatever i could to make money
because every time you couldn't so i
figured out a way i could
and then i met a man one man who showed
me
that i could change my brain he showed
me that i could develop
a new cluster of beliefs that i
am good enough i am worthy enough i am
smart enough i can achieve what i want
to achieve i can
learn and it's easy for me i can earn
any amount of money i choose i can
learn whatever i need to learn to earn
any amount of money i
choose and so i started at 19
doing daily affirmations i recorded my
affirmations i listed them for a
freaking
you know two three hours a day in my car
as i was driving
i wrote out my goals i recorded my goals
i was taught how to create a new imprint
into my non-conscious brain which is
where your beliefs are
anyway and i started to re-pattern
re-script and reshape
my belief patterns my perception of
what's possible
and while i was doing that my mentor
says great let's upgrade your knowledge
and your skills so we raise your level
of confidence
and certainty i want you to read this
book i want you to listen to this audio
i want you to do this i want you to
practice one hour a day
on your skills so you get better so as
i raise my self confidence
and my certainty and my belief in myself
and i developed some good habits boom
one thing started clicking after another
at 19 i made 31 000 bucks at 20
i made 151 thousand dollars 26
i started building my own company and
did a billion dollars in sales four
years later by the time i started
feeding tom i
i actually i didn't know what was wrong
with me at that point because the
symptoms seemed so
physical and seemed so brain-based i was
scared if i was honest i wouldn't have
imagined that
as i dove down and began to peel back
the onion and unpack all of this that
this was related
to overwhelming emotions in childhood
that was not my first path of
exploration
my first path of exploration was what is
wrong with me
um by that time just kind of going back
on the physical side of things for me
i had had headaches my whole life i had
had brain fog or kind of that
that fogginess not really feeling like
my brain was awake
all of the time my whole life out of
nowhere as i entered into my 30s i
started to forget my words
mid-sentence memory issues that i always
kind of had
now seemed i seem to have a really hard
time even remembering things that
happened last week
for instance and then out of the blue i
started fainting so of course i was like
this must be something wrong with my
brain
what is it and when i dove into research
i then met all of this you know work on
epigenetics
and the effect that our daily choices
and or events that happen to us have on
our physical bodies
diving in deeper i really understood my
nervous system
and now i understood my fainting as the
the effects of accumulated years
of living in that dysregulated nervous
system
so now that i understood what the cause
of it was
which goes into my definition of
holistic holistic for me
not only means honoring our mind our
body and our soul the interconnectedness
of our being
it also means exploring what for many of
us
are the deeper underlying imbalances
that are causing
what we're calling symptoms or even
diagnosis or syndromes
right so now that i understood oh
for me this fainting could be a symptom
of something deeper
could be a symptom of how i'm treating
my body and how dysregulated my nervous
system
is so as i began to dive into this
research i noticed something else
how disconnected i was to my body so
once i build the foundation of
consciousness that we just talked about
once i began to teach myself how to
safely
inhabit my body i began to do some
nervous system
regulation techniques and tools the
quickest and easiest
one that we all carry around with us is
around breath work
and i started to tune into how was i
breathing
just checking in with my natural flow of
breath
and i realized that like many people who
struggle with anxiety
i had a really shallow chest breath
i noticed that sometimes tom when i'm
really stressed out
i hold my breath i actually don't really
breathe much
at all and what i learned is each time i
do both of those things
either just breathe really shallowly or
i'm holding my breath
i'm actually contributing to my anxiety
because i'm
keeping my nervous system locked in that
fight-or-flight mode
so i learned a new way to breathe i
learned how to use my belly
which was hard at first because all of
my posture
was reflective of all of this
constriction and all of this
threatening kind of posture and stance
of a lifetime
though once i accessed my belly i
learned that i could learn how to bring
teach my body can you walk people
through how you did that because
um belly breathing diaphragmatic
breathing changed
my life so i'd be curious to know what
tools you use for that
yeah so for a lot of us who struggle
with our posture
it's hard um so back straight shoulders
back
so i started laying down it was
difficult for me so i would
begin my practice either right before
bed or right when i woke up when i was
already laying
and for me it started with just a small
daily promise
of five breaths from my deep belly area
for me putting my hand on my belly
physically so i could feel it
when it would expand and when it would
deflate was really helpful so that was
just a daily promise
every time every morning or right before
bed i would put my hand on my belly
and just practice practice practice but
then like i said
i wanted to become more aware of how i
was using my breath all day long
and then building on that foundation can
i harness my breath
all day long when now life's happening
and i have the actual things to be
stressed out about right
can i use my breath to regulate myself
in those moments
what happens when we meditate and what
exactly is meditation
so i want to share with you a secret
meditation
is often often often like misunderstood
in the western world
because we think it's about clearing
your mind focusing on your breath
getting very peaceful and that's true
that's getting into alpha that's
relaxation
but you can go way deeper you can be
able to go into deeper levels of
meditation
to source ideas to source inspiration so
for example
when i wrote the code of the
extraordinary mind it took me a long
time to
get chapter one ready it took me almost
three years to finish chapter one
chapter nine of the book which was
called live your quest
i wrote an eight hour slap the original
chapter nine was something i wasn't
happy with
i had five days to submit my book to my
editor and i woke up one day before
christmas and i realized gosh i
freaking hate chapter nine and all of a
sudden i feel this idea form in my head
and i sat down for eight hours and
retyped and rewrote the entire chapter
nine from scratch
the book went to print and two years
later a documentary filmmaker came to me
and said hey i want to make a
documentary about your ideas and they
picked chapter 9
chapter 9 of that book became the live
your quest documentary
which got nominated for an emmy award
but it was
all written and conceived in eight hours
now what was going on there
i had inadvertently tapped into
certain altered states to download the
information
these states are accessible to all of us
what
consciousness ability one person might
have
we all have because we're all made of
the same stuff
we're kind of hooked by as an adult is
from
whatever we took away from our childhood
right so in my second book i talked
about this like
what are the elements that you took away
what have you built your life upon
of all the things that you could have
taken what did you take
right and so when you question that with
somebody and somebody says you know like
my mother was controlling okay which is
a descriptive term
of things you saw okay when i say my
mother was controlling
that's not just a phrase i'm knowing a
world
that exists now between her and i right
and in this world that i'm in with her
it's not my perspective i'm actually
watching her do things
that confirm what i've come to believe
i mean i completely ignored all the
other stuff
but i want to focus on that [ __ ] right
because this to me is the big deal
and so when i say to somebody but what
if your mom isn't controlling
and they say well she is and i say i
know but what if she's not but if you
just let go of the notion that she's
controlling
well i'm not going to let go without why
she's ruined my life
i say no you've ruined your own life and
then people start to fight
for the narrative why because they've
built the life upon it
and they've told other people about it
and they've got a consensus around them
and so they filled the life with these
people are like yeah your mother's
controlling and you're like yeah that's
right she is
and then when i go into my relationship
as an adult this person is not going to
control me
and even if that person is controlling
me or not controlling me i'm going to
point to all the ways that i think they
are
and then it's like i've married my
mother no
you're indulging your perspective and
you never get to see anyone beyond your
own perspective
and that's very confronting for someone
because if you've spent
10 20 30 40 years there's a carnage
there might be divorces there might be
bankruptcies
built on the illusion of control
and and then it's like then you start to
see like i've
i haven't been interacting with life
i've been interacting with my
my my view of it my judgment of it my
opinion of it
and that's sometimes really challenging
for somebody stomach i want to take you
away from thinking of seduction
as just the sort of thing that men do on
women or women do on men
it's something that permeates our
culture it's in advertising it's in
marketing it's on the internet
it's in politics it's different
obviously a sexual seduction is not it's
the same as kennedy seducing the
american public
but the dynamics the casting of the
spell the enchantment has a similar
a similar process so first of all
there's the desire to
to be a seducer which a lot of people
will say oh i don't want that i'm not
interested in that
and what i'd say in the book is remember
the time that you've
that you experienced probably in your
life when another person had fallen in
love with you
and you sensed that you had power over
them
that they were under your spell that
they were that the things that you said
excited them and interested in them that
the walls the resistance that people
normally have are so frustrating you
can't reach your kids
you can't reach your wife your people at
work they're closed to you
and in that moment when someone had
fallen in love that wall
came down and you had this sort of back
and forth
electricity it's amazing you love it
it's powerful
it's great you want that you want you
don't want to be
you don't want the sexual version of it
in your office
obviously but you want to be able to
persuade to get people
to lower some of their usual walls and
resistance to you
so the first thing is you want seduction
in your life believe me
you want it the other thing is
you have a misconception about seduction
it's not this
as you say this villainous male you know
kind of
figuring out these very cold calculating
strategies
that's not what it's about it's there's
there's got to be a naturalness to it
if you're someone that has calculated
their way too much
in in the process of this is what i'm
going to do step a b
and c it's not seductive people can read
it
seduction there's a body language to it
there's a kind of
communication and we sense that another
person is trying too hard
they've read a book they read the art of
seduction and they're applying
the 24 strategies it's it doesn't work
you have to bring out natural qualities
that you have
and i maintain in the book that every
person has
a kind of natural quality that makes
them
authentically seductive so in general i
believe that
most mental health disorders in fact i
would say almost every mental health
disorder
originates in childhood experience and
originates as a coping mechanism
now if you look at anxiety if i were to
pull a gun on you
you would not be anxious you'd be afraid
as you should be
so when are we afraid
when we're threatened with something
either something bad happened to us
or something that we perceive as we need
as something that we need is
threatened to be taken away from us now
in the early child's life in a young in
a young child's early life
anxiety is an attachment alarm what is
the child's biggest need
attachment with the parent connection
with the parent when the parents not
around
the child should feel some fear that
serves a positive purpose
because when the child feels fear he
cries
she vocalizes and that brings the parent
i mean look at her mother cat responding
to the kittens
cries you know immediate and the same
with the instinct
with human beings who are still
connected to the apparently
parenting instinct they will respond to
the child's cry for help
so that fear is adaptive
so it's a coping mechanism but now what
happens
to a person whose parents are taught
by medical experts like i used to
until i learned otherwise or others not
to pick up the kids when they're crying
now that natural fear
that causes the crying that brings the
parent
which ends the anxiety is embedded in
the child
so what begins as a coping mechanism now
becomes generalized
so under certain circumstances there
should be fear and anxiety
but when i have this anxiety when
there's no immediate threat
what is that about it's not a response
to anything external
it's the embedded anxiety that i
developed as a child
now in a society that makes people more
isolated all the time
that uh where where human social contact
is replaced by
the rather cold and and impersonal world
of the internet
and when people under genuine threat
where young people
have less opportunity for meaningful
employment and belonging and a sense of
purpose
than they than their parents used to
there's
more general threat now when that
general threat hits people
who are in childhood
over immersed in anxiety that's not
relieved by the parent coming to help
them
now you've got an anxiety situation so
when it comes to your friends with
anxiety
i would um get them to really look at
their childhoods
and to recognize that that anxiety is
really
the cry of some desperate childhood part
of themselves for help
and and to learn to get help with that
part
not to not just take tranquilizers or to
drink booze not to feel the anxiety
or not to go on the internet to to
soothe themselves or to
escape momentarily but to actually see
that that anxiety is a normal response
on their part
to what actually happened to them and
that it can be
relieved and recovered from if they look
at its sources
even the genetic mistakes that are
associated with disease
depends on how you live your life and
very simple things like sleep
meditation and stress management
movement
yoga and pranayama now yoga and pranam
goes way beyond exercise because with
yoga and pranayam
there's a particular nerve in the body
called the vagus nerve it's the tenth
nerve
and the word vegas is a latin word but
it's
related to the english word vagabond so
this nerve comes from the midbrain
it influences your facial expressions so
you can now
do micro expressions and see if a person
is happy or not
it influences the eye movements
it influences the tone of your voice are
you threatened are you stressed are you
friendly are you happy
it influences your heart rate activity
then it pierces the diaphragm
and it influences the activity of every
other
branch of the vagus nerve that goes to
all the organs in the body
so when i discovered this through yoga
teachers and masters
i realized that the yoga asanas you know
we say yoga asana
and people usually translate that in
to as postures but actually the word
asana means seat
as you know seat of awareness seat of
consciousness
so each yogasana is a particular seat of
consciousness that stimulates a
particular nerve that
is going to uh organ in your body
and the only reason for that nerve is
self-regulation or healing
or homeostasis so when i discovered that
i became
fanatic about yoga i haven't missed yoga
now for as long as i can remember that's
amazing
wow okay not one day of yoga or
meditation
or um but then you have to understand a
bit more of psychology because
humans are hardwired to recreate what
they know
we like what's familiar even if that's
very even if it's very bad if i've never
had money and i win the lottery
i'm gonna get rid of it or if i've never
had love and you love me
i'm going to reject you because it's so
unfamiliar if i've had a dad who calls
me an idiot
and worthless guess what kind of guy i
like
that's it because when i meet them i go
oh i feel like i've known this guy my
whole life we just clicked and they
think oh my god it's because he's my dad
but i've been sleeping with him for six
months i don't know what to do with that
now
because we are wired to like what is
familiar
and to resist what's unfamiliar and
that's what kept
us alive when we lived in waters you
didn't go i'm a bit bored with this
group i think i'll go outside the walled
city and find another tribe because they
might have
killed you so we have this wiring that
says
run towards what's familiar and run away
from what's unfamiliar
but the very good news is you can make
anything
familiar and the most important thing to
make familiar is praising yourself
that's if you could just do that that in
itself would change
your entire life how do you praise
yourself
well you get out in the morning and go
i'm a good person
i have a skill i have a town i have
something to offer the world i'm here
for a reason
you look in the mirror and go oh there
you are you're a good person you got a
good heart you know
the most important way to answer that
question is this
what did you always want your dad to
tell you even if you never had a dad
if you had a dad a good dad what would
he have said
what would your mama said what would a
nice teacher have said to you and it
would be something like this
i'm proud of you you're a good son
i'm so glad i'm your dad how lucky i got
to have you
and a teacher would say you're such a
smart kid what a joy it is to teach you
because you're smart
and we all want to hear the same stuff i
love you i'm proud of you
you're interesting you're a great
company nobody needs to hear i'm the
best dentist in beverly hills because
that doesn't work
it's emotions and many of my clients
their mother might be dead but they're
still trying to get her to approve of
them
dad's living in another country but
they're still working to make him like
them
and you know the most important thing is
you like you so whatever you wanted to
hear
say it to yourself because your mind
doesn't even know
that it's coming it also doesn't care
your mind doesn't care what you tell it
is right or wrong
or true or false or even if it's good or
bad it lets it in
like chapstick on your lips your lips
don't go is this organic
fair trade just lets it in it needs a
bit of nourishment
and we need some nourishment and words
are very nourishing and there is
actually nothing on the planet
that will raise your self-esteem like
praise
but self-praise is better because i said
to you i
just adore you you're amazing by the way
you know
can you do this and this and this i've
manipulated you
but if i say it to myself my mind knows
there's no manipulation
and the mind likes repetition and when
you say every day your mind kind of goes
oh yeah here you go again with that
praise you say it every day
must be true and now it sinks in there's
a lot of emerging science saying
here's the reality and anyone who wants
to dismiss it
is denying science which is planet earth
is a tiny planet in a galaxy
of trillions of planets
um my friend deepak chopra was on my
stage uh
at one of my events a few months ago
he's a lovely man he just radiates
goodness
and um he took us on a tour de force
about cosmology
and he's been a pioneer for so many
years and he confirmed the science which
is we are all part of an energy source
whatever you want to call it
god uh nature life and you're
absolutely right jay your intentions are
creative so we could come at it from a
cosmo
cosmological point of view when you say
here's who i want to be
you know this morning in my journaling
i'm going to meet jay
i'm so delighted and blessed that he's
invited me
on his show because he influences so
many people
how may i serve that intention
hopefully is creative so we're very
powerful
i'll come at it another way which is
epigenetics
epigenetics as you know stands for the
emerging field of science which is you
are not your genome
the old school said your dna what you
get from mom and dad
that's your destiny we're now realizing
that
epigenetics means our environment our
daily rituals like getting up at 5 a.m
our thoughts what we eat our peer group
etc
literally affects the up regulation or
down regulation
of our genome what does that mean it
means
if you believe in yourself if you do the
work in the journaling if you get up at
5am and do that victory hour and go
through the 20 2020 formula
you literally are recalibrating who you
will become out in the world
so you're absolutely right then you
start channeling your intentions
and you start stepping into your power
like we are awesomely powerful beings
most of us have blocked our our intimacy
with our true power sometimes you know
oh i can't sleep at night because i'm
thinking about something and
usually what i'll do is go write it down
i have some writing to do so i get up
and i go write down what i'm thinking
and that usually does the trick
but because i had been playing with
youtube i thought
well i'll try making youtube video
and telling people what i'm thinking
about and and see
if that performs the same uh
function as writing and to me the
function of writing well it's twofold
one is conceivably to communicate with
people
although the fundamental purpose for me
is to
clarify my thoughts so that i know to
you know because if
something is disturbing you what that
means is that it needs to be
articulated it what it's the emergence
of unexplored territory
something that disturbs you that that's
the right way to think about it it's
unmapped territory that's manifesting
itself
it's like a vista of threat and
possibility and you need to articulate a
path through it
and so that's what i was doing it's like
i was thinking well this is bothering me
and this seems to be why and here's what
i think is going on and
and so i made the videos and in some
sense i i didn't think
anything more of it so i'm curious we
could start there about
how important is mental health for our
length
of living and the quality of our life
and what can we do
to increase the quality of our mental
health you know i think it's something
that
has been so ignored um typically by by
medicine and i think part of it has to
do with just the stigma that's
associated with mental health
and that can be depression uh in a
formal sense where we have a diagnosis
of depression
or mania hypomania bipolar schizophrenia
all these things that you know sort of
get labeled by a diagnostic criteria but
frankly i think it goes much broader
than that it basically comes down to how
well do we all
cope with distress because life is
stressful
and whether it's really big stress like
loss of job due to covet or loss of a
spouse or divorce
or just frankly the day in and day out
kind of grind of life
the the tools that we have to cope with
that distress
and maintain kind of a buffer uh within
which we function
really determines so much of the quality
of our life
and when people come to me as patients
most of them are paradoxically not
saying
the the silly things you might expect
which is i i want to live forever i'm in
pursuit of immortality no i think most
people are saying
i would love it if i could live a little
bit longer and that's called lifespan
living longer and extending life but
i'm more interested in extending my
health span which is the quality of my
life
and so to that end health span has three
pieces right it's the
cognitive piece so how well does your
brain work as you age
and we could talk about what makes up
what makes up cognition
then there's the physical piece so
you know basically what we think of as
the exoskeleton right so your bone
mineral density
your muscle mass function ability to
move
freedom from pain all of those things
and then of course this
this third piece which we just talked
about which is the emotional resilience
and the ability to maintain a tolerance
around distress and again those three
things to my mind sort of
form the boundaries of quality of life
when any of those are lacking
even in the absence of disease right you
could have no
no imminent death on your doorstep but
if if your
cognition is sliding if your physical
body is breaking down through injury or
if you're just
emotionally unwell it doesn't seem to
matter that much
[Music]
if you want to hack and condition your
brain for success check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there we have a huge
frontal lobe and it's 40
of our entire brain and most people
uh when they have a thought they just
think that that's the truth
and i think one of my greatest
realizations